-Our next guest
is Tony-nominated
and Grammy Award-winning actor.
He's currently
starring on Broadway
in "Gutenberg! The Musical!",
now playing at
the James Earl Jones Theatre.
Please welcome back
to the show,
our friend Andrew Rannells,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
-Hi!
It feels like it's been
a very long time
since I've been here.
Hi, Syd.
-I think, in person, 2019.
So it has been a bit of time.
-There's been --
Yes, I saw photos...
-Yeah.
-...of this very thing.
-And we looked great.
-We did look great.
We look the same.
-And we look the same now.
-Nothing has changed.
-I had your friend and co-star
Josh Gad on the show.
You seem upset
that he was here.
-No, no, no, no, I just kind
of thought this was my thing.
[ Laughter ]
And, you know,
he's, like, an L.A. guy,
and I was like,
"This is sort of my show."
-Oh, yeah. Like,
you're kind of a Seth guest.
And he's kind of like
an out-there guest.
-Somebody. Yeah.
-Yeah.
It was --
-But it was fine.
That was nice of you
to be so nice to him.
-Yes.
-I appreciate that.
He's very fragile.
-Yeah.
And L.A. people, like,
they scare easily.
-Oh, my God.
They're super scared.
But, yeah, I really did
drag him --
Because that was his first time
doing your show,
and I was like,
"Oh, I've done it like 10,"
which I don't think is true,
but it's probably close.
-It's pretty close.
You'd round it up to 10.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-He was talking about --
And we were
talking about Broadway
and tiny dressing rooms.
-Yes, we do have
tiny dressing rooms.
-The proximity
of dressing rooms.
-We are right
next to each other.
You would think maybe
we would have gotten
a little bit farther apart,
but, no, that's not the case.
-Because the entire show
is the two of you
on stage together.
-It's just the two of us.
We have a three-person band
on stage with us,
and just Josh and I.
So we're in this
little space together.
-He was talking about
your warm-up before the show.
Do you warm up
in the same way or --
-We do not.
No, Josh, um...
Josh's vocal warm-up
is, like, mostly like '80s,
like, power ballads.
-Yeah.
-And I stick to more sort of
traditional, like, musical
theater things to warm up to.
But recently,
it's been very strange.
Our dresser, Alex Bartlett,
and I have been very confused.
Sometimes during intermission,
Josh will go into
his dressing room and listen to,
like, acoustic versions of
"Everybody Hurts" or "Creep"
or, like --
Like, it's really --
it gets real dark,
and we're like, "Joshy..."
-And that's a very counter
energy to the play.
-No, yeah.
This show is like --
it's, like, all high energy.
And Josh is in there like,
I guess,
slowly rocking in the dark.
I don't know what he's doing.
[ Laughter ]
But I'm concerned.
-They are long days
when you have double shows.
He was saying that he will ta--
he will lie on a --
He will take a nap on a cot
that you have described
as his FEMA cot.
-Well, it is
a little jarring.
Usually --
Yeah, I mean, I'm all for naps.
Don't get me wrong.
But he does sleep
like sort of an infant.
And he sleeps wherever
and whenever he can.
So they have, like,
a full rollaway bed
that he pulls into his room
from the hallway
and just lays down and, I guess,
cries himself to sleep.
I don't know.
-Due to his acoustic --
his acoustic sad-song mix.
-Yeah, but he takes --
he takes a lot of naps.
I mean, naps are important.
Broadway is hard.
-Broadway is hard.
-Eight shows. You know,
it's a very active show.
It's just the two of us.
-Just the two of you.
Now, one nice thing, though,
is, the audience
doesn't play a role, but there's
no fourth wall in the show.
So you get to talk
to the audience.
-Which is a good thing
and a bad thing, as you know.
Like, opening the door
to the audience of, like,
there's sort of a false sense
of, like,
"Do we participate?"
and the answer is no.
[ Laughter ]
-They're there to be spoken to.
-You do not get to participate.
So -- Well, you know,
we are introducing ourselves,
and we're explaining the show
and -- and, you know,
most of the time,
most audiences are fantastic.
And then some audiences,
we get some -- like, some jokers
who are like, "Hey, Olaf!"
You know,
and they do some like...
"That's not what
we're doing, sir."
-And do you just basically
have the -- have the permission
to say that to them?
-Kind of. Yeah.
In this show.
I mean, I --
Yes, I have, like,
a little bit more --
What's the best way to say this?
A tiny, more experience
in front of a live audience
than Josh does.
This is Josh's first time back.
I'm talking about him
like he's dead.
But he's -- it's his first time
back to Broadway
since "The Book of Mormon."
-Yeah.
-Whoo!
-And -- thank you.
And, Josh --
You know,
the general rule of improv,
Seth, is, "Yes, and..."
-"Yes, and..."
-Correct?
-Whatever your partner says,
you got to roll with it.
-So, you know,
inevitably things will go wrong
in a Broadway show,
and in this show,
we sort of differentiate
all these different characters
we play by wearing these hats
with the characters' names
on them,
and, usually,
everything goes fine.
And sometimes there's
a little --
you know,
there can be a little kerfuffle
or, you know, it's a new show.
We were in previews, so there
are some changes and stuff.
So, one night,
we were doing the show,
and I skipped like four pages.
[ Laughter ]
Like, four full pages.
And -- But in my mind,
I was thinking about it,
and I was like, "Well, I could
try to go back, but why?"
And I was like, "It's probably
for the better for everyone,
for the crew.
Everyone wants to go home."
So I just kind of kept going
and just was like,
"We'll just
skip the four pages."
-And were you making
eye contact with him
as if to be like,
"I acknowledge I missed it,
but let's keep going"?
-Well, that's on me.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Perhaps I didn't
do that clearly enough,
but his improv, to me, was,
"You don't know
where the [bleep] you are."
[ Laughter ]
-He said that on stage
for the audience to hear.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that's not good improv
at all.
-No. And to which I replied,
"No, I don't."
And then we got back on track.
But it was not --
-That's not kind.
-It was, "No, but..."
-Did he make you go back,
or did you keep going?
-Oh, I kept going.
-Yeah, yeah.
You can't then --
-I punished them all.
-You know why you can't?
Because if you then went back,
the audience would see
exactly how much you'd missed
when you got back to the place
you were at.
-And I'll be honest,
I have no clue what I missed.
And I really did.
I went backstage,
and I was like,
"I know I missed a lot."
And they were like,
"It's four pages."
I was like, "Oh, okay.
Well..."
-You also have a very
cool thing in the show.
There is a cameo every night.
-Oh, yes. Yes, we do.
We have a special guest cameo.
-And do you -- how far
in advance do you know
who the cameo will be?
-Sometimes the day of.
-Gotcha.
-You know, but we do rehearse
with the person
a little bit before.
So we actually
just had your friend
and also fellow Omahan
Amber Ruffin.
-Amber Ruffin, the great
Amber Ruffin, in the show.
-Who killed it.
Was hilarious.
-You also -- the show is called
"Gutenberg!" and you just had --
-We had Steve Guttenberg.
-You had Steve Guttenberg.
-Steve Guttenberg, spelled
with two T's, in case
anyone's keeping track.
"Gutenberg" is --
Johann is with one,
Steve is with two.
No, he was fantastic.
And I -- you know, he was
a huge part of my childhood.
And he's, like, in so many
movies from that time.
-That you watch on VHS tape
a thousand times each.
-A thousand times.
Yeah. So that was very exciting.
-Alex Timbers is the director.
Alex Timbers.
-Wonderful director.
-Fantastic director.
-A collaborative director.
-Very collaborative, yes.
-But yet you've worked
with directors in the past --
Have you ever received notes
from directors that you were
maybe trying to be constructive
but rang a little...?
-Yeah, early on,
I think sometimes they get --
Well,
what am I saying, early on?
Sometimes still today.
[ Laughter ]
...get impatient,
and they want to say --
And I'm all for it.
Like, if you want it
faster or louder...
-Yeah.
-...just say faster or louder.
'Cause sometimes people
can get into like,
"Well, I wonder if there
should be more immediacy."
You're like, "You mean faster."
[ Laughter ]
"You want it faster?
That's great."
So I like to cut to the chase.
Don't get me wrong.
-Right.
-But I did have a director --
He gave me --
I used to keep them
'cause he would write his notes
down and hand them out.
My favorites were
"Quit acting with your hair."
[ Laughter ]
That's a good one.
"Charming is not a choice."
[ Laughter ]
I beg to differ.
I could choose to be a dick
right now, but I'm not.
And, um -- oh, the other
good one was,
"Andrew,
you are not James Dean,"
which I don't really know
how that applied to the show
we were doing, but I think maybe
he was just tired or confused.
-He was like, "I got to give him
a note on today."
-Something.
-"Let him know who he's not."
-"You're not James Dean." Okay.
-Yeah, I have to say --
Can I say something?
I think "Book of Mormon"
would've sucked with James Dean.
-Thank you.
-Yeah.
-He would've just, like,
mumbled his way through it.
-Way too broody.
-Not fun at all.
-Really -- Yeah.
So I'm glad I'm not James Dean.
-Yeah.
-It worked out.
-I'm even happier.
-But I'm still acting
with my hair, so take that.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And can I say something?
You're very charming
when you do it.
Yeah, and it's a choice.
-Seth!
-It's a choice I care for.
-Come on.
-You guys,
that's Andrew Rannells.
"Gutenberg! The Musical!"
is playing now
at the James Earl Jones Theatre.
Go see it, and stick around.
Be right back with Jesmyn Ward.